hey this is presh tallwalker
1
divided by
the cube root of 25
plus the cube root of 5
plus 1
is equal to a times the cube root of 25
plus b times the cube root of five plus
c
if a b and c are rational numbers what
is the sum of a b and c
i think then may for the suggestion
the video if you'd like to give this
problem a try and when you're ready keep
watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
i will first present a hint to solve
this problem and then i will go over a
solution
first let's go over the sum and
differences of cubes
construct one cube whose sides are equal
to x
this cube has a volume equal to x cubed
construct another cube whose sides are
equal to y
this cube has a volume equal to y cubed
x cubed minus y cubed will be the
difference in volumes of these cubes
one way to express this volume is x
cubed minus y cubed
the other way is to look at the volume
that remains from the larger cube when
we subtract the volume of the smaller
cube
we can calculate this volume by looking
at the sum of three different cuboids
one cuboid has dimensions of x x and x
minus y
this will have a volume that's equal to
x minus y the quantity multiplied by x
squared
another will have dimensions that are
equal to y x and x minus y
this will have a volume that's equal to
x y multiplied by the quantity x minus y
and a third
will have dimensions that are equal to y
x minus y and y
the volume of this is equal to y squared
multiplied by x minus y
so we have two ways to represent the
volume that remains when we take the
large cube minus the small cube
thus these two volumes are equal
we now look at this algebraic formula
let's simplify it
the three terms on the right hand side
each have a factor of x minus y
so we can factor it out
we thus simplify this formula and we get
x cubed minus y cubed is equal to the
factor x minus y multiplied by the
factor x squared plus x y plus y squared
for completeness i'll mention we can
also get the sum of cubes formula from
this
we will make this substitution that y is
equal to negative z
we substitute this in and then we will
carefully simplify
the result will be the sum of cube's
formula
that x cubed plus z cubed is equal to
the factor x plus z multiplied by the
factor x squared minus x z plus z
squared
now let's solve the problem
1 divided by the cube root of 25 plus
the cube root of 5 plus 1
is equal to 1 divided by the cube root
of five squared plus the cube root of
five plus one
let x equal the cube root of five
the denominator then becomes x squared
plus x plus one
now this factor in the denominator is
reminiscent of the factor in the
difference of cubes
suppose y is equal to one
one factor becomes x squared plus x plus
one and the other factor is x minus one
the product of these two factors is
equal to x cubed minus one
if we substitute x is equal to the cube
root of five
then x cubed is equal to five
then five minus one is equal to four
from here we can see that we can
rationalize the denominator by
multiplying the numerator and
denominator by the factor x minus one
this is the rationalizing factor
the denominator then is equal to four
and the numerator is equal to x minus
one
so simplifying we get x minus one all
over four
we divide through by four to get one
fourth x minus one over four
then x is equal to the cube root of 5 so
we get 1 over 4 multiplied by the cube
root of 5 minus 1 over 4.
we now equate this to the original
equation a multiplied by the cube root
of 25 plus b multiplied by the cube root
of five plus c
we can then equate coefficients to get
that a is equal to zero
b is equal to one over four and c is
equal to negative one over four thus a
plus b plus c
is equal to zero
and that's the answer
i want to end the video with a little
bit of extra credit
suppose
one divided by the 4th root of 27
plus the 4th root of 9 plus the 4th root
of 3 plus 1
is equal to a multiplied by the 4th root
of 27 plus b multiplied by the 4th root
of 9 plus c multiplied by the 4th root
of 3 plus d
if a b c and d are rational numbers
what is the sum of a b c and d
i'll post an answer in the comments give
it a try thanks for making us one of the
best communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
you